♪ ♪ ♪
l'arrivée des éboueurs.
Le ballet quotidien du ramassage
des ordures.
Les citoyens apportent eux-mêmes
leurs sacs à ordure,
de table.
de Lettre à Élise de Beethoven.
Mais il y a des règles
de conduite, rappelle cette
femme venue porter ses déchets
fait pas la file correctement",
dit-elle.
Personne n'y échappe. Même
les peticelui-ci doivent apports
déchets pour la collecte.
Ça fait partie de son travail.
n passe deux fois
par soir.
Et si l'on ne vit pas tout
près d'un point de collecte?
Cet homme doit marcher trois
ses déchets.
Tous les soirs, sans faute.
Chaque fois, celui-ci arrive
tôt avec ses sacs à ordure
pour croiser amis et voisins.
C'est l'occasion de se mettre
à jour sur les nouvellestier.
Apporter soi-même ses ordures
communautaire, croit ce
responsable. Même si la majorité
des Taïwanais rencontrés disent
qu'il s'agit plutôt d'une tâche
Cette façon un peu ludique
de responsabilisernsabilisernsïs
et de les sensibiliser à la
protection environnementale aars
les années 90, Taïwan était
souvent surnommée "l'île
aux déchets".
Les citoyens paient une taxe
pour leur volume
de déchets. Seuls les sacs
à ordure gouvernementaux
les acheter. Le grand coûte
l'équival'équival'équival'équivs
et le petit, 8 cents.
"L'île est populeuse et l'espace
pour les déchets très limité",
un incitatif pour les citoyens.
Moins vous produisez de déchez ,
moins ça vous coûte cher
en achat de sacs.
Depuis l'instauration de
ce nouveau système à Taïpei
en 1998, le taux de recyclage
est passé d'environ 2,5 % à
Il faut cependant que
les municipalités arrivent
à tout recycler, prévient
cet expert, il y a un goulot
d'étranglement depuis quelques
Le réflexe pavlovien est
aujourd'hui si fort à Taïwan...
♪ ♪ ♪
... que cette femme pense
à sortir ses ordure chaque fois
qu'elle entend la mélodie
de Beethoven, peu importe
Cette valse des dé
profondément ancrée dans
le quotidien des Taïwanais.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taïwan